Marcus I was going through the afm
Twitter and I just found this article
that's 13 frequently used phrases that
make you sound like a Hollywood rookie
by Stephanie Palmer and it's a funny
article but there's some really
interesting stuff in here that I
actually wouldn't know or have known
that it would make someone sound like a
rookie so number one 13 phrases to avoid
she writes high-concept and I'm just
wondering what your thoughts are I'm
just doing you know cuz I I know you'll
have something interesting to say she
says if your idea is high concept it's
obvious it's not if it's not saying it
won't help we've had a lot of interest
which means to a decision-maker this is
code for lots of people I've read it but
none of them have liked it enough to get
involved with the right cast dot dot dot
everyone knows that basically um this is
a very unique project which means it's a
red flag if it's unique
you haven't done enough research to
understand I understand the job genre
excuse me that's good oh it has its with
a message meaning when you're
highlighting that there is a message
this means that you're focused primarily
on teaching the audience a lesson
instead of telling a great story so just
just your thoughts on some of these oh
and one last one sorry I've been working
on this film for 11 years she says
you're committed okay possibly inept so
we're having fun with it but but how
much truth do you do here in some of
this and and you know I think God bless
everybody
you know these articles I take them all
with a grain of salt because I know
there's no road I mean to say you know
these things are going to make you look
like is to indicate that okay these are
the things that you do correctly and if
you do these things correctly then
things will go the right way and there
is no correct the only correct is like
someone writing you a check
and that can happen no matter what you
say you can say this is a really unique
story and someone can say I agree with
you and then they write you a check
which makes that completely null and
void you can say we've had a lot of
interest and someone can say well let me
look at it I'm interested and then they
write a check which makes that saying
knowing void you can't say the right
thing to the wrong person I think that's
the real only thing you can't say the
right thing to the wrong person and you
can't say the wrong thing to the right
person and I think that means that if
it's not gonna work for somebody you
can't make it work for somebody you know
I don't think how you say something if
it's coming from a place of truth in you
is gonna make the difference like if
you've got an incredible script and
you've got like a really good set of
whatever you're supposed to have behind
it but you use one of these phrases
someone who really is in love with your
project isn't gonna say god I love this
script and he's got so much great energy
and I really want to work with this
person but he used a rookie time hmm nah
I better not cuz they used a rookie time
I was gonna do that you know what I mean
like you either find the people who are
your tribe you find the people that dig
what it is that you're looking to do or
you don't and you know in that point you
either decide I'm just gonna keep
looking or you throw in the towel but I
don't think it comes down to say this or
that or I don't know maybe it does I who
knows I don't know but I just I just
think if you're coming from a real place
and and you're putting your best work
out there
you just got to keep pushing until you
find the right person you know
you